43 the best bull riders from around the
world are in las vegas this week how
cool is that they're all competing for
the gold belt and cold hard cash in the
pbr world finals and who better to get
out there
and try it out we've got bianca holmen
live at t-mobile speaking with a
competitor so bianca you're not going to
compete but at least you get to talk to
one
yes if you remember you guys you know
two years ago i actually got to get on a
bull but this year we're out here with
one of the stock contractors one of the
youngest and one of the baddest i'd like
to say addy drury from oklahoma so tell
us about your bull here i think you're
going to feed them for us right yeah his
name is hard labor and as a
baby his mom abandoned him and we
bottle-fed him and now he's just this
big all right look at him here we go you
got some feed there is he going to
respond to it
hard labor come on over
i don't know but also tell us about uh
flanking this here tell us about this
competition that you do
um well the flank what you do
is you
um
put this loop through it
then you loop it around
on their waist
and then
they'll try to kick it off and that's
how they buck all right so again she
handles the bulls and then of course we
got our bull riders we're joined here by
dakota lewis from montana and i hear
well just like addie how you know being
around bulls is in the family riding
bulls is in the family for you yeah i
grew up in a rodeo family and uh
bull riding's been definitely a priority
for most of my life so uh pretty
fortunate to be here at the world finals
how does it be here to be competing
against the best you know again this is
like the super bowl you were telling me
yeah no this is the absolute best bull
riding in the world the finals that's
what we go all year for to
do good here and uh electricity here
just makes you want to do that much
better so to be here is
truly a blessing for sure for sure and
also i gotta ask you about the training
you do because you can't just get on
there and just say oh i'ma do this you
have to really train for this sport yeah
you got to be in good physical shape as
long as a good mental shape i mean if
you don't think you can then you
probably can't so in this this
sport you definitely have to be all in
so all right well again this is a great
competition from the stock contractors
to the bull riders and then actually the
livestock the bulls is he gonna turn
around for us
maybe maybe let's see if we can get him
come on
he's try he's being a camera he's being
camera shy right now but again if you
want to see these bulls live in person
here the pbr happening this weekend here
in las vegas at t-mobile arena we're
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio uh bianchi he's just showing off
the finer end of
he's like
the business end the business end
he needs a moment he needs a moment
right now it's too early apparently he
didn't get his starbucks this morning
thank you
no starbucks for him